There are so many new
beauty releases happening
all the time, so we gathered some of the
most-hyped products to test for ourselves.
I've never tried a Plouise product before,
but I kept seeing this blush everywhere.
It's The Cheek of It liquid blush.
The formula is actually water-based,
so it did blend into
my skin really easily.
I think maybe because it's water-based,
it wasn't as pigmented
as I expected it to be.
I did add quite a bit more
to build up the color,
but I think it turned out pretty,
and it didn't move any of
the product I already had on.
Even though I liked the end result,
I think I've tried better liquid blushes.
This lipstick keeps
selling out everywhere,
but I finally got my
hands on a couple shades.
This is the Revlon Super
Lustrous Glass Shine lipstick.
It's one of those lipsticks
that kind of mimics a gloss,
so you get this really
pretty sheer wash of color
and that high-shine finish.
These are beautiful and
feel so good on the lips,
so I totally get the hype.
They actually remind me of
the Hourglass glossy balms,
except these are, like, $20 cheaper.
Miss A is that website
where all of the makeup
is super affordable.
I saw people raving about
their AOA Plush Blush,
so I had to try it.
The packaging is literally
like a nail polish,
so it just felt a little odd applying,
but I was really impressed with this.
It's a gel formula, so it's
more like a cheek stain
that feels lightweight.
These blend out so easily,
and they are very pigmented.
I really, really love these.
I also picked up the new AOA
Flaw Eraser foundation sticks.
I got a few shades so I could bronze
and highlight with these as well.
I got nervous about how
these were going to look
on my skin when I was applying,
because they felt thick,
but once I started blending
it out with my brush
and I picked up the extra
product with my sponge,
it was so much better.
I wasn't expecting these
to be so full coverage.
It is more of a matte formula,
but I don't think it
made my skin look dry.
And all of my other products
went on top of this just fine.
I can't believe both of
these products are under $2.
Charlotte Tilbury just released
this Hollywood Glow Glide
Face Architect highlighter.
I got the shade Pillow Talk Glow.
It's supposed to give this
sort of soft-focus glow,
rather than be super glittery.
It also has emollients in
it to hydrate the skin,
which, I don't think I've ever tried
a hydrating powder highlighter.
I'm torn on this product
because from afar,
I think it looks really
beautiful, but up close,
I feel like it made my
skin look a bit textured.
To be fair, my skin
hasn't been great lately.
It's been really dry,
and I've been getting little breakouts,
so highlighter is probably the
last thing I need right now.
I do think this is really pretty.
I just don't think it works great
if you already have texture.
I don't think I've purchased
a CoverGirl product
since high school, but these
glosses were calling my name.
This is the new Yummy Gloss.
These smell incredible.
The pinky-clear one
smells like a piña colada,
and the more burgundy
one smells like berries.
The scents really took me back
to, like, old-school Lip Smackers.
They have this huge doe-foot applicator,
which I'm a fan of, and they
feel so good on the lips,
super shiny and not sticky at all.
I do have to mention that
the product description
doesn't say this is a plumping gloss,
but I got this tingly feeling
on my lips when I applied it.
I don't know if it's
because it is plumping
and they just weren't
super clear about that
or if I'm allergic to something in it,
but either way, just had to let you know.
Made by Mitchell released powder versions
of its liquid Blurshes and bronzers.
I'm not saying blush weird,
that's just what they're called.
I do have to say I'm not
a fan of the packaging,
just because it's not
an easy shape to store.
But on to the actual products
inside the packaging,
the pigment on these is unreal.
I tapped my brush off a lot,
and I still got full color payoff.
This powder formula is
still easy to blend, though.
It was easy to diffuse the color
without it getting patchy
or ruining my foundation.
They just look really smooth on the skin.
I love these.
ELF recently released a
line of color correctors.
I picked up the peach shade
to brighten up my under-eyes.
This formula is really
creamy and easy to work with.
I was worried it was almost too peach
when I was applying it,
but my concealer blended on
top of this really nicely.
It actually did add some brightness,
and you cannot beat that $4 price point.
Makeup by Mario has finally released
its long-awaited SurrealSkin foundation.
Looking at it in the
bottle, it looked glittery.
I think because there's mica in it.
The formula itself feels slightly thick,
but it did feel weightless
once I applied it to my face.
This covers a lot.
Like, I couldn't see
any of my discoloration
or acne through this.
I do think that this foundation
did enhance my texture, though.
I mentioned in my last video
that my skin hasn't been great lately,
but I still do good skin
prep before foundation.
This just kind of highlighted
those problem areas.
I do think it worked well
with all of my other products.
I want to try this again
once my skin texture
gets a little better, because
the coverage is great,
but I'm not 100% sold on this.
This is the Kaleidos
Mono blush in Dreamwalk.
This kind of blue-based
pink, almost lilac color
has been so popular lately.
I was worried that it would
look weird on my skin tone,
but I actually thought this was so pretty.
This formula is so silky smooth.
It blends out beautifully,
and the pigment was on the softer side
but totally buildable
and easy to work with.
I like this color way more
than I thought I would.
These are the Kiss
imPress press-on falsies.
So these are press-on
lashes that don't need glue,
and you apply them underneath your lashes
instead of above, so
it looks more natural.
I'm not gonna lie, I had
a really difficult time
figuring these out. I
don't wear falsies often,
so I'm already not great at applying them,
but this application
process felt so much harder.
Because you apply them below the lashes,
it made my eyes water, which in turn
made the lashes not stick very well.
I tried pressing them
together with my real lashes
using the tweezers and my fingers,
but they didn't feel secure at all.
If I blinked too fast,
they would just pop off.
These have a lot of great reviews,
so they just might not be right for me
and my sensitive eyes.
I just think applying falsies
with glue feels a lot more secure.
This is the REM Beauty Midnight Shadows
lustrous liquid eyeshadow
in the shade Fembot.
I've tried out this formula before,
but this shade in particular
is having a moment on TikTok.
It's this sheer pinky-nude color
with a bunch of iridescent
blue sparkles in it.
It's really beautiful
and shifty on the eyes.
I do think the best way to apply it
is with your fingers.
This formula does dry down quickly,
but it looks so cool,
and it doesn't settle in
the creases of my lids.
ELF just released these
O Face satin lipsticks,
so I picked up a couple shades.
I'm just gonna say it.
These are incredible.
They are so creamy and
comfortable on the lips.
They just glide on, and
the pigment is unreal.
Like, these are one-swipe
lipsticks for $9.
They are a satin lipstick,
so they do transfer,
but they are so good.
I've been really excited to try this
Urban Decay Quickie 24-hour multiuse
hydrating full-coverage concealer.
It's huge, and it has a
brush attached on top.
This shade was a little too dark for me,
but I tried to make it work.
I applied it in all the areas I normally
apply concealer, and
I usually like to wait
a couple minutes before I blend it out,
but this one dries down very fast.
I did have a bit of trouble blending,
but I was immediately impressed
by the coverage this gives.
I also think this brush is actually good,
but I think the bristles are too short.
I do think it's interesting
that it's described as
a hydrating concealer,
because to me it leans
more natural to matte.
But this is a really good
full-coverage concealer.
We have a new product from Rare Beauty.
This is the Positive Light
under-eye brightener.
It has this metal applicator
that's supposed to be
cooling for the under-eyes.
I blended this out with my fingers,
and the coverage is definitely sheer,
but I do think it brightened.
I added a little more, and
it does build up nicely
while still feeling weightless.
I applied my concealer on top,
and it blended out just fine.
I think this formula layers really well,
and even though the brightening
is on the more subtle side,
I can definitely see a difference.
This is the Dior Addict Lip
Maximizer plumping gloss.
This gloss looks so glittery and beautiful
in every single video
I've ever seen of it,
but unfortunately, I didn't like it.
The applicator is pretty small,
especially by today's standards,
but that's not my biggest issue with it.
It's the glitter.
The glitter in this
feels gritty on the lips.
Like, when I rub my lips together,
I can feel all that glitter,
and the plumping aspect
was, like, nonexistent.
I saw and felt zero plumping.
I wanted to love it
because it looks pretty,
but in my opinion, it's so not worth it.
Let's talk about the L'Oréal
Telescopic Lift mascara.
It has what they describe as
a "double-hook bristle brush,"
which is supposed to give you
an instant lift and volume.
I asked my editor, Natalie,
to show the full application
process with no cuts,
so you can see how this
mascara actually performs.
I do really like how it
makes my lashes look,
but the brush is not my favorite.
It picks up a ridiculous
amount of product.
Look how much product I
scraped off the brush.
I felt like I spent most
of the time applying
just trying to remove excess product
so it wouldn't look clumpy.
I also got the waterproof version,
and I found this formula
a lot easier to control.
I think I prefer the waterproof version.
I wouldn't say this mascara
makes it look like I'm wearing falsies,
but it definitely gives me a lot
of length and lift, and
I will keep using it.